so where are the Defenders of women you
remember Gloria Steinem famously said if
men could get pregnant abortion would be
a Sacrament now she's going to house
hearing saying men can get pregnant
so karadansky probably doesn't vote for
the same people we vote for but she's
one of the only people we know who is
persistently defended the right of women
to exist and we are grateful for that
she's President of the U.S chapter of
women's declaration International author
of the book the abolition of sex she
joins US Senate karadanski thanks for
coming on and I'm sorry to make fun of
it because it is of course going to
destroy civilization itself but it is
kind of amazing that all these
self-aware well-educated people are
saying this stuff that actually is a
huge middle finger in the face of women
everywhere
it is it's horrible thanks so much for
having me uh giving uh women of Courage
award to a man on International women's
day is of course appalling and
disgusting to feminists including myself
who fight for the rights privacy and
safety of women and girls and also it's
not more horrible than anything else
that's gone on in terms of the Erasure
of women and girls throughout Society we
are all expected to accept men who claim
to be women either simply by saying that
they are or by undergoing hormonal and
or surgical treatment to make themselves
appear maybe slightly more like women
and we're all just supposed to accept it
and go along I do want to take quick
issue with your assertion that feminism
is dead I am here to assure viewers
feminism is not dead but where I will
agree with you is that mainstream
feminist organizations organizations
that claim to be feminist including
organizations like Planned Parenthood
and the National Organization for Women
and the national Center for lesbian
rights have completely caved to what is
in effect an industry fueled men's
Rights Movement so I'll agree with you
on that but there are those of us on the
political left who call ourselves
radical feminists and we will not stop
fighting for women and girls
what do you think the I mean the average
person on any issue has no voice at all
in this country and that's I think
becoming more true with the day but do
you think the average woman sees this as
insulting as a man I can as who actually
likes women this seems like the most
insulting possible thing I can imagine
do you think it's perceived that way
I do and you know the other day I came
across really interesting polling that
suggested that people who consider
themselves to be either very liberal or
liberal around 70 to 75 percent know
that sex is real know that sex doesn't
change so when you're referring to
liberals going along with this of course
you're absolutely right that the
Democratic party is pushing this and the
sort of democratic uh liberal Elite is
pushing this but ordinary Americans
across the political Spectrum are not
going along and yes I absolutely think
that ordinary average American women see
this as insulting what they may not
realize though is that it's no more
insulting than the so-called trans
movement has been to women and girls for
years now
that's right that's right and I
appreciate your saying so I know it's
probably not a natural move to come in
the show but we're grateful that you do
karadansky thank you thanks so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight